that's a good man my spirit back we
gotta play some more doorways alrighty
then
whoa hello where the [ __ ] am I oh I'm
staring at a wall nice ok hi everybody
how's it going don't like this place
well why am i so fast what am I going
alright it's gotta be fine respect
where's thank god damn it how the [ __ ]
are we or supposed to go up here oh it
is holy [ __ ] ah gosh ok it looks like
we're gonna go even deeper in this
hellhole wish it oh ed get farted again
oh yeah oh oh [ __ ] this is double
nightmare Oh God
seriously my dog has been farting like
[ __ ] all day oh god I'm so sick of it ah
oh it smell so bad
this is like a real interactive horror
experience right now god damn it huh
where are we
hello hello I just want to go home to
mama pelts well what the hell are you
whoa are these torturing machine that is
a nice hat I would love to have that hat
that doesn't look like a comfort fashion
these days man women do all kinds of
things still looks pretty I don't
understand it
well the light China oh oh oh [ __ ]
I didn't even see you guys what is going
on here oh this game look I I know as a
[ __ ] the noises everything this is so
spooky this is literally spookier than
your mom's tits and I've seen that [ __ ]
it's not beautiful what am i doing
hello oh oh it's the helmet be awesome
hat [ __ ] man I'm gonna get so many
ladies now that I look old swagalicious
huh
so I gotta look for all this stuff is
that it
hello oh there's a thing there oh I need
to put a thing there isn't that isn't
that right let's try and find all this
[ __ ] for whoa I don't like the
atmosphere banged your back hype helps
how you don't not very good at all
whatever this Bojack laudatory look oh
god nipples dude that's gross man did I
do something did I do it
I think I did it I think I did it by
simply pulling it oh my god damn genius
there what did I sacrifice banked I
sacrifice banked that was the best
puzzle solve Elbert Oh too bad he's gone
though
well he had to be sacrificed so much to
do about it
all right what do we got here I would
assume they put one of these big in
between oh [ __ ] how many do you how many
do you need
shut up atmosphere and being busy by
being scared
oh god we're over now oh [ __ ] that's the
share isn't it is no what is what are
you what about what do I do with you I
don't think I have anything for you no I
only have my awesome little hat yes what
you have a really dark voice man yeah I
know well what are you though and don't
worry about it all right
you see I have a little hole inside of
me I do see that guess what it's for
[ __ ] don't I don't I don't want to
guess you can do whatever you want with
my body Pierce shut up
get away I don't like you come back when
you need me [ __ ]
oh look finding all cancer [ __ ] here
[Applause]
that looks like something I don't want
in my butt a lot of things actually
looks like anything okay I don't worry
my buddy hi let's not get sidetracked
here okay
there will a fortune now you are all
right I think we're making great
progress here I'm proud of myself
and you all right what woody is here now
hey what's your name hello Bert I can't
spin around for you shut up my you some
big pets
why I just wanna love you well I'm all
out of love baby oh [ __ ] it's not
another note okay so I use I use that
thing
okay got it Oh tough luck don't hurt me
please
don't hurt me please don't hurt me I
mean I don't care whatever what I have
like I don't care like I did not look
very happy
yeah I don't get it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm going out of here
I don't think we got in here oh it's
here
all right let's see if we can squeeze
whoa
damn girl so the lights goes off when
I'm finished this is the heart making
machine I think no it's a spinner
everything I think that is some nice
[ __ ] main well life is life
nananananana god is so [ __ ] creepy -
how many did we do
[Music]
what are you they had it's this a how to
making machine I don't get it
which one is this one oh yeah what's the
thing there oh I said I said my bad we
can do this [ __ ] for us we can torture
people
oh nice boobs whoa there's something
blowing here nice I didn't see you
before I'll take that thank you very
very much
see see see why would you torture that
girl she seemed wonderful I mean she had
great personalities get it I was a joke
okay I guess I kind of ruined it a
little bit I think we all have the wheel
of fortune left or in the hat making
machine of course of course
I don't think you're a hat making
machine now
I can only assume it oh yeah what is
wrong with people
isn't it crazy that you used to torture
people like that isn't that I'll think
about it
that's just god damn it why would you do
that why what is it people are just mean
man humans used to be sly clearly evil
like seriously oh and I need to I need
the other thing right yeah this one
needed to stop I'm pretty sure
Oh Oh the tits oh oh they're still there
oh thank god okay I think that was all
of them we can only help press I might
have cause uh hello
please let nothing bad happen to me
because oh god I have so many goosebumps
right now I don't even know I like I
could go to Germany and I wouldn't even
realize it
holy [ __ ] I must have forgotten
something I swear to God I forgot
something I don't have any items hello
oh okay I'll guess I'll go in here then
Oh God
hi hi hi
[Applause]
going up no we're going down [ __ ] I want
all my nipples are diamonds right now
holy [ __ ]
they're like pesky little Friskies what
it crashed alright we're back this place
is big I don't like this I'm fast again
which I do like what do we do what is
this
Alexander if you look Islamic or feel
Gothenburg no no I have to redo that
that's that's the best the best [ __ ]
I've ever heard but yeah I'm in the game
yeah
Felix Lumbergh Gothenburg Sweden a
horror game that's so funny
wait I accidentally clicked away Felix
learned body Gothenburg Sweden
maybe it isn't me what is happening
[Music]
is it stuck or something oh okay it is
we don't have any items so I guess I
need to find something whatever got here
a wheel a cog wheel well who would do
that
what kind of idiot would put it over
here the COG wheel obviously needs to be
in here tah-dah oh [ __ ]
not so awesome that hasn't been a
monster in this game yet and that
worries me a lot because I know that
[ __ ] that's gonna come eventually
whoa the game looks the level design is
so good like it looks so cool oh god I
don't like this oh god no I really don't
like this I can't tell if I'm really
short or if the game is really big well
is that whoa what the [ __ ] what is
happening in here what what did I just
get myself into Oh what stop
Oh God oh god what is happening what is
happening hello
oh oh oh okay don't hurt me
I'm a gentle Swedish man I am I love
sculptures all right press I'm gonna
have to end this part here but I hope
you enjoyed watching leave a like if you
want the next part I really appreciate
all the support and always you bros are
the best say awesome
here's the brofist we go before Eliza
[Music]
what is wrong with me Miley before and
after